in many ways there is something
analogous
to the protests which reliably became
riots that were taking place
in portland almost every night for well
over half a year
um and in other cities as well with some
less regularity in that
um there are you know and you know the
treatment obviously from the media of
these
these two sets of events is wildly
wildly different but in both cases
it is not a single uniform group and so
just as people on the right um
decrying every single person who went
out into the streets to support black
lives matter
were wrong to do so because this was not
a single
uniform force and not by far the vast
majority of people
who are protesting on the streets uh in
in portland for instance and elsewhere
did not become rioters
but a reliable portion of people almost
every night did
and um it sounds like i don't know what
the ratios are we may never know but
you know just as there was some rally uh
that
uh that included a wide variety of
people
most of whom had never had no intention
of and would not have gotten wrapped up
into
uh what you're calling an insurrection a
siege on the capitol
but that doesn't mean that some small
proportion of people didn't do that and
in both cases the rioting
whether or not it's on a federal
building in downtown portland or the
actual capitol building in washington dc
is totally unacceptable oh completely
unacceptable
now one does have to deal with
and i talked about this on the
trigonometry
podcast one does have to deal with the
fact
that the united states was born in an
insurrection
and so there is an acknowledgement in
our
you know our foundational principles
that there are there are
events that uh call for
something well beyond civil disobedience
in fact
um can we just show very quickly here
zach my screen
uh wall street journal op-ed from uh
three days ago actually from a former
princeton fellow as well aaron zubia
uh called the founder's guide to knock
down drag out fighting
uh the sub title the sub-headline here
being the ratification debates of
1787-88 were colored by quote patriotic
enthusiasms verging on violent chaos
again not a justification just an
historical
correction of sorts uh that are
our rosy image of history as if the u.s
was born
uh you know sort of aphrodite like on
the half shell
and everyone was thrilled with it is
certainly not true yeah
certainly certainly not true but you
know
so i i will say this whole conversation
takes place uh with a certain amount of
you know i'm tempted to say trepidation
but let's just call it fear
there's a certain amount of fear that
what is
taking place on the major platforms
is coming for us and that the
important points that we are trying to
make will not only be
lost but that are
attempting to make them may hasten
what will likely come for us not for the
first time so we will come back to this
but
um but in any case i want to i want to
somehow make this point and to the
extent
that darkhorse might disappear from
this platform i want you to remember
that i made it
okay and the point is
you have a lot of people responding
to a garbagey understanding of what is
taking place
right you have the q anon right right
which has a misunderstanding about where
we are
not that there i i don't know almost
anything about the
detail of the content of q anon but it's
an
overly packaged view of what has gone
wrong it has
filled a vacuum of information about
what really
runs society this is
again the counterpart
of the confused understanding over on
the blm antifa
uh black bloc left right which has the
sense that
our civilization is so evil and so
far above others with respect to
how much harm it has done that the only
response to it
is to tear down its structures right
that that cannot
possibly make things worse and will
inevitably make things better
that is an equally confused
understanding of where we are and so
you cannot have a society in which every
individual
gets to decide for themself when you
have reached a moment
that you are obligated to rebel against
the structures and tear them down
right you can't have everybody waking up
each morning and deciding whether
they're in a unabomber
uh mood or not right so
to the extent that the founders of the
country
rebelled against a tyrannical governance
structure they were very clear-headed on
why they were doing it and they were
united and it was clearly justified and
what we have here
is a small insurrection into the capital
that is somehow the fringe i mean it's
almost
physically the fringe of this much
larger protest that was at the capitol
which is itself the fringe
of the conservative movement right so
anyway you've got these things it's like
a physical gradient
and you've got people who are you know
wearing the viking helmets and carrying
the confederate flags breaching the
capital that's obviously completely
unacceptable
and uh and it is an insurrection even
according
to many of them right you'll see this in
in
what they say into cameras um
however i think it is also incumbent on
us to recognize
there are some very i know nothing about
the
improvised explosive devices that were
we are told
were found at the capitol
i did see an image of somebody who
appeared to be
a a protester who had
zip ties of the kind you would use to
bind somebody's hands these are very
troubling facts as are the confederate
flag the
camp auschwitz t-shirt
you know these are hallmarks of
something
uh completely out of control
on the other hand completely unhinged
on the other hand what i didn't see
these are right wingers were any of them
armed
i assume they must have been um but
one did not see a lot of firearms in the
circumstance so
what you have is an insurrection a an
egregious violation of the law one that
is not
justified by our circumstances
but done in a way that is clearly
intended to be in some sense
symbolic right so i'm not justifying it
but what i'm saying is that a
honest broker would have to parse all of
this
nuance and that unfortunately
what we are getting this idea that we
can decide what
who's right enough to listen to that we
can take anybody
who is engaging any idea that has been
formally dismissed
and tossed them off platforms and things
is going to result in the worsening of
the problem
that caused the rioting this summer and
the worsening of the problem that caused
the breach of the capital which is
people don't have good information to go
on why don't they have good information
to go on
lots of different reasons including
mundane algorithm stuff
but but the point is this is what
happens
in the vacuum of analysis is you get
this kind of confusion you get q
on confusion on the one side and antifa
confusion on the other side
and if you want this not to characterize
the way we are going forward
the thing to do is not to try to police
speech online that's a perfectly insane
response to this it's going to make it
worse
the right thing to do is to let those of
us who know how
to engage these difficult questions
responsibly
do it will we make errors of course but
that's the nature of
[Music]
civilization
[Music]
you